veni et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a amené
ma grand-mère a pratiqué la photo j'ai
retrouvé j'ai à la maison dès la pente
helmand point commun de cette douzaine
de couples
tous ont immortalisé le plus beau jour
de leur vie au château de talcy de mai à
septembre prochain le monument organise
une exposition sur les photos de mariage
prise sur son site une exposition qui
s'effectuera avec la participation de
chacun alors tout le monde est venu
apporter son album souvenir s'aperçoit
qu'en fait tu désires les gens nous
prennent complètement l'album est pas
quelques photos donc après de vie c'est
quelqu'un qui sait quelque chose quand
même des maisons
voilà c'est à dire qu'il faut prendre le
temps si on ne peut pas venir faire un
dépôt un constat d'état dépôt provisoire
oui mais c'est une vie c'est high et sur
les photos on a des enfants les enfants
des fois il y avait il avait
effectivement les cousins les cousines
d'anciennes photos de noces affichés sur
les murs du château
mais pas seulement les volontaires
pourront également faire une photo
réactualisée de leur mariage ce couple
marié en l'an 2000 a déjà une petite
idée de la mise en scène pour
l'organisation du mariage
on a fait appel à nos filleuls on nous
accompagner donc c'est déjà important
pour nous et on va se permettre d'être
contactés pour savoir s'ils peuvent son
sac un petit peu de temps et de revenir
vingt ans plus tard sur sur cet endroit
à cet endroit avec pour essayer de
refaire les mêmes photos avec 20 ans des
cadres et 6 pour les couples
l'initiative est l'occasion de revivre
des souvenirs heureux
l'exposition doit également permettre
aux habitants de se réapproprier leur
château le château tel ci a beaucoup
d'histoires de strates
mais il ne faut pas omettre celle des
habitants je dis aussi mariage d'un jour
mariage de toujours quel que soit
l'avenir de ce mariage mais certains
peut-être un prétexte en soi mais de
rencontrer gagne rencontre dans le
mariage et vient de rencontrer si entre
le château et ses habitants
l'organisation espère que d'autres
mariées jeunes ou moins jeunes viendront
apporter de nouvelles photos pour
compléter l'exposition deux nouvelles
journées de dépôt sont prévus les 7 et
14 mars prochains